we are getting ready for cpac cpac is
the conservative political action
conference earlier in the show and
earlier in the week i told you about
some of the people that would be
speaking donald trump will be speaking
donald trump jr will be speaking
kimberly guilfoyle will be speaking uh
you know charlie kirk and different
members of congress
tulsi gabbard will be speaking sort of a
shock to some because she was a democrat
and ran as a democrat but
of course she's extremely reactionary
and fits in much better with the fox
news crowd than with any leftists i know
she will be speaking at cpac so the
speakers are one side of it my colleague
john pointed out to me that he was
looking at the sponsors list for cpac
and a lot of them are the usual suspects
but there's some pretty weird stuff so
you know if you look at the sponsors
page you see that fox nation is
sponsoring that's fox news's streaming
platform you see that some of the big
sponsors are the japanese conservative
union that might sound weird but that
there's actually a big trump japan
movement
uh the republican national committee is
sponsoring and you know a whole bunch of
others you look at partnering sponsors
and the epic times which are a
right-wing media outlet getter which is
like a right-wing twitter they're all
sponsoring you then look at supporting
sponsors and it's a lot of the common
ones heritage foundation and other think
tanks tea party patriots action on and
on you look at contributing sponsors and
it's turning point usa and others you
then look at participating sponsors and
you still see some names you recognize
right side broadcasting network and
others and then you go to exhibitors and
there's a whole list of stuff that we
don't really recognize and one of them
in particular caught my eye caught
john's eye and he told me about it and
it's called enemies within the church
this is just unbelievable and we could
pick any one of these and do this but
let's just look at this one enemies
within the church is i guess that you
would call it a documentary film
and
what they seem to be arguing is
the church has now been infected with
left-wing propaganda the film which
we're going to look at the trailer of
here
feels that the institution of the church
is too liberal and it's basically going
communist just like they feel our
colleges have this this is incredible
who would fund this trash look at the
trailer let's listen what happened
to the church
to the living powerful transformative
nation-shaking christianity
what they're trying to do
is completely demolish western
civilization and then to rebuild it
in a just society
how do you break down american
christianity
i think the problem today in our culture
is many of our words have been co-opted
and stolen and dumbed down and reversed
social justice is sold as something that
it isn't
critical race this is dystopia porn over
the church being too liver liberal
understand that that's the core here
theory is sold as something that it
isn't
whiteness has caused blindness of heart
whiteness has caused blindness of heart
when you preach victimization it always
leads to vengeance advice us against
them me against you i want my pound of
flesh american churches today
are where the universities were 10 years
ago pretty heavily marxist they're not
quite there yet but they're well on the
way many of the seminaries and bible
colleges are definitely already there
that message that they're going out and
taking the world is not you need to
repent of your sin
receive christ instead the message that
you actually have is they are under the
weight of racism or sexism or homophobia
and then we need to unify them together
i'm gay i'm 29 i'm a youth pastor in new
jersey uh-oh nothing more dangerous than
a gay youth pastor guys these people are
really out there and this is the new
target the the church liberal churches
is the new enemy
i'm straight and i'm also a youth pastor
of new jersey we're planning on sharing
life together for the rest of our lives
which we're not totally sure what that
looks like
obviously nick is straight and he does
plan on getting married
when he has a wife one day she'll make
those decisions with us the future
damage of what we're doing now is just
going to be enormous the entire fabric
of family personal wealth private
property all those things are out the
door now understand that
when you
stake out the position
that
college no college is liberal
indoctrination you send your kids to
college it's going to be a real problem
there can't do it
uh regular elementary school no no no no
kids are being taught about slavery
and uh you got a homeschool christian
homeschooling church well church is fine
right
that's the safe place for this idea
no the churches are becoming marxist
uh social justice
um places and though you gotta keep your
kids out of that they are going in the
direction of the only place that's okay
is some small cult-like enclave that is
quite frankly reminiscent of of jim
jones right the the drink the kool-aid
people at the end of the day that's what
they are building here you're only safe
in your little cult even the church is
dangerous now
and everything is the state they believe
the state is god they don't define
justice the same way as the scripture oh
no there's going to be an equality all
right
and it's going to be a totalitarian
marxist justice
so that's just we get and again we could
we could look at a ton of these that's
one spot exhibitor
at cpac the people who feel
churches are become and they use uh they
they use
um all sorts of communist imagery there
as well if you were just listening the
church has become a communist
marxist
social justice
entryway
into dangerous leftism according to
these folks now the funny thing is
if this actually had the effect of
weakening the lobbying power of churches
it might actually be a good thing the
problem is what they're advocating is
get out of those churches come to the
right churches make sure they remain
fully funded etc we're going to be
covering cpac and it's going to be
insane the sponsors are insane the
exhibitors are radical it's all crazy
but as i said yesterday
we don't have this level of organization
on the left
we we just don't we and we need it
and part of why the country keeps going
to the left
but they keep winning elections is
because they have this level of
organization they have this level of
funding
um and it's it's not at some point it
will hurt the left
it is hurting the left it has hurt the
left for a very long time